hello my name is Jimmy couple and I live
a dual life by day I work at MIT I'm a
researcher I work on program synthesis
programs that write programs by night I
lead workshops teaching software
engineers like yourself how to write
better code today I'm going to talk
about something from intersection of
both worlds software engineering advice
today is confusing for anything you read
online you'll find someone else arguing
the opposite and today I want to ask the
question how do we find a source of
truth in software engineering advice
this whole situation reminds me of
another a source for truth how do you
prevent scurvy scurvy is an ancient
disease caused by a vitamin C deficiency
and after thousands of years of deaths
finally the 1700s a British scientist
named James Lind proved in experiments
the cure eats interest and so on by the
end of the century
the world Navy had started requiring all
of their sailors to drink lemon juice
scurvy rates went from crippling to
almost none but then in the 19th century
they lost the cure they didn't
understand well enough they thought
lemons why not lines big mistake as a
result there are multiple wages the
poles as late as 1910 in which everyone
got scurvy and people died now imagine
that you are an 18th century sailor and
you ask the powers-that-be how can I
prevent scurvy the answer comes eat
citrus but wait lemons not limes and
weights do not boil it and wait do not
store the juice in copper if you store
it in copper it's worthless this is kind
of starting to sound like witch doctor
now compare a sovereign earring advice
well but first so before I get there so
from this I coined the term citrus
advice the advice to eat citrus is good
advice save people but it was not
precise enough to capture the reality
and so it came with this long list of
caveats that made it hard to use the
precise advice is to get vitamin C and
Walt took about two hundred years to get
from citrus to vitamin C this is the
ideal to be aiming for the simple thing
that explains all of the caveats now
compare soften earring advice the Guru
says discover abstractions to make your
code shorter okay I abstract in my code
no that is the wrong abstraction a
duplication is better than the wrong
abstraction well then how do I know if n
abstraction is good design well you see
good design leads to simplicity okay I
simplified my API no you broke your API
and if you break your API that creates
complexity for other programmers so this
advice not so easy its citrus advice and
I think that if you were to take these
four people three people these are all
close to but not actual quotes by these
people
you've heard of show them the same piece
of code and that's the same question you
would get similar advice which go to
show you that they have some deeper
intuition about some deeper reality that
these words are not precise enough to
capture so how do we get to more precise
engineering advice many years ago I got
really into program synthesis program
synthesis is amazing you like it's this
program where you just give them stuff
like you tell what you want to do on
this input it should do this maybe
here's a little bit of information what
the permit should look like and it
thinks for a while with its algorithm
and it gives you a correct program it's
cool but a really nice thing is that
you cannot BS a synthesizer you cannot
be as a synthesizer and you cannot be as
a synthesizer if you ask the programmer
hey Bob if I do this thing will it make
it easier for us to program later on
it's gonna be a pretty vague question
hard to answer but if you ask if I do
this this way will it make it easier to
synthesize the algorithms on paper you
can just look at it get an answer and if
you want to know if I have this data
formats of the millions and millions of
possible code second writes is anything
that's clean you can just try it's
humanly examples get an answer now so
we're going to look at the parallels
between synthesis and human programming
we're going to dive into the different
schools of synthesis Marly speaking
there are three kinds inductive
synthesisers theorem proving logic
enumerative searchings very cleverly
through larger web programs this is how
your database optimize your sequel
queries by the way in your video
synthesis and using constraints offers
in the interest of time we're mostly
going to talk about the doctor today a
little bit about constraint based not no
enumerative but there is a very
important fourth school of synthesis and
in fact we have a few hundred examples
of them in this room and that is you you
are a synthesizer you write programs and
while you might work a little bit
differently than these other algorithms
you do not have the constraints all in
your head
although I do think you do work a bit
like needed octave synthesizer and do
that kind of deductive reasoning there
is only one universe of possible
programs only one universe of possible
algorithms for writing programs and so
we can but looking at these other
schools of synthesis we can learn
insights that we can take into our own
programming and that is the thesis of
today's talk
and throughout our journey the synthesis
lands we will see three common recurring
themes of abstractions constraints and
logic enter her deductive synthesis at a
high level the deficit Isis is about
taking a high-low idea and through a
series of mechanical transformations
make it more and more refined and
precise until you reach an
implementation so what is the
information the dr. synthesizer works
with look at this I can we talk about
software can broadly categorize we're
saying at one of three levels here's a
max function you can talk about the
runtime values what does it do on this
inputs or you can talk about all inputs
and look at the code so runtime is level
one code level two but this is not
capturing the Y of the code it doesn't
explain why it works it does not explain
how you came up with it that information
is in the bagua the logic in the
derivation or proof and I call this
level three as you might guess from the
relative size of these boxes the most
information lies in level three but this
is the Y this is the stuff that's only
in your head normally but to add to a
synthesizer this is just as concrete as
the code it outputs at the end so let's
look at it from the synthesizers
perspective so quick background here's
what the judge synthesized it looks like
so it has some goal like I need to get
an integer which the maximum do other
dangerous and you write down a logical
formula for where that means for us
specify it in some way and so our goal
is we're given two integers and we want
to programs just after running the
program then this condition it's the
maxim gives it two inputs will be true
it's two it's tools it has a bunch of
rules that that relates
a piece of code to the abstract logical
meaning of the program and now can give
a search so we want this maximum okay
what's probably getting running the if
rule now we know the outer skeleton is
an if and we have two sub goals to prove
and we go into the search maybe we try
if again okay let's try another rule
another rule okay maybe using if there
was not a good idea it's trying to
assignment instead ah that works there's
my assignment now I know a little bit
more about the program and it keeps
going like this and eventually it gets
the actual program so that was 40 year
old the sentence is nutshell but you
also see this I get a lot of newer
systems if you're at Nadia's talk an
hour ago you saw her talk about a
deductive synthesizer called sing quit
nadia was a post talking in my lab the
world of synthesis is very small and
here are a couple other systems lambda
squared and Fiat all these only do is
small fictional programs because
synthesis is very hard which is why
instead of actually using this day I'll
tell you to not use it but instead learn
the insights and used to improve the
only algorithms within your head and by
looking at things this lens dr.
synthesis we can come up with some
deeper insights educator let's look at
specification level missions I'm Ronnie
a web app and I need sanitized rings no
XSS attacks so ever just sanitized a
string I escaped all single quotes and
now I have to choice and ratted use this
before I save my data to disk
it must be sanitized and in do it either
by calling the sanitize function that I
just wrote or by doing it by hand and
take a few seconds to look at these
decide whether you prefer option 1 or
option 2
so so when I've shown this beats program
programs before it's say a plurality
prefer option one a slightly smaller
number have no opinion and as small
minority for option two
and in a minutes we'll give you a sense
in which often one is a correct answer
there's some interpretations but so how
else when you come out to come to this
conclusion well you might have use the
folk engineering advice and it's like
it's more abstract but the others more
direct and this ones aren't as one
happening it's more to understand easier
to change and when you're not working at
this level it's based like two lawyers
in the podium arguing with their side
and both of them have case law to
support them it's it's hard to get a
real right answer and even if you do it
might not be good enough so here's an
engineer that I used to train let's call
him Steven and his head is full of
citrus advice he looks at this and says
option one it centralizes the code good
job Steven
but his understanding of the information
hiding was not deep enough
cuz five minutes later I gave him a
similar example so this time I have my
Twitter box and I type in two hundred
thirty nine characters and it says too
long what it's because it escapes my
string and in double counted every
single quote because every single quote
became two characters so let's not do
that
let's MA let's undo count two single
quotes and I'm very glad that the Python
standard library has his count function
it made this slide easier to write but I
propose the Fed of doing maths we
abstract this counting priests an entire
string into a function and Steven looks
at this he says no option one mistake of
the slides to say option one is
over-engineering this is pretty much for
abstraction evil in a moment we shall
see how there is a
of all that takes often one in both
circumstances and if you adhere to this
principle then not only is option to dis
preferable it is wrong and my wrong
I mean compile air level wrong this
comes the idea of encapsulating ideas
information hiding is not about private
methods and caps and classes not
encapsulating ideas and what the f does
that mean so this is one of those vague
things you might have heard before where
once you learn to think like a
synthesizer and actually see the logic
it's based on it it becomes very precise
and so let's do it and so through this
lens of deduction and it's after
synthesis we're going to we'll see you
option 1 is is preferable in information
hiding how easy to think about and how
easy it is to write and give precise
meanings to all three of these lines and
let's begin by talking about when we
mean by sanitized well right now it
means that every single quote is escaped
and I can write this down as formally in
one of many notations I'm going to use
Coke because I'm familiar with it but
you can pick any of these others maybe
you learned one of these earlier today
that's another session it looks like
this says I before every single quote
there's a backslash and now what other
modules can use this definition when
they're reading about code but there's
something missing here which is really
that definition I gave us sanitize
that's just today's definition and other
models can use it but what if tomorrow I
decide I need to escape other things
I've changed meaning being sanitized now
all this other code that in the
reasoning used the fact that this is
what sanitize means there's an air
broken so what I want is to is to put
all current and future meanings is
sanitized behind some abstract predicate
and say I'll give this string it is
sanitized what even it's sanitized it's
sanitized and that's final
and now like this sanitization module
can change its mind about what it means
by sanitized and no one will ever know
it's a secret and that is an abstraction
barrier
do not cross now and you might have seen
a diagram like this before
oh I centralize my functionality I wrap
it in a function you can't you can't
expose it this is not like that this is
purely an idea this sanitized predicate
does not correspond to anything your
code is just how you think about the
code and I let slide you'll see exactly
how so in cork you write this idea of an
opaque predicate an existential
predicate with the opaque keyword again
you can do this in about any other
formalism that is this is the
abstraction boundary but written as code
and now other modules do not to think it
but in detail all I know is I got a
sanitized thing that whatever that means
it's a black box so this is the sense in
which option 2 is wrong because in order
to look at that code and read it as a
human and say I'm going to justify why
this is we're doing what I once you have
to do somewhere you're ahead access the
information that sanitized rings have
single quotes escaped and nothing else
escaped and so this actually doing is
it's piercing the abstraction barrier do
not cross
and relying on this old piece of
information that may change dangerous
whereas an often one all the information
about what sanitize means is
encapsulated into the sanitization
module so maybe the sanitized sterlin
function which is right next anodized is
allowed to know what it means to be
sanitized but this user code is not and
set thus it is a secret secret preserve
they may be changed
and the same view the sanitized
predicate gives us the answer to the
first question so here my sanitize
function returns was returned means it
returns the sanitize string whatever
that means and before I say I have to
feed it in a sanitized string whatever
that means and so when I put these
functions together they line up but when
I try to sanitize it by hand
it's like you you gave me string where
your scapel single quotes I need to say
that I string I don't know that these
are the same what do you mean that that
is a sanitized drain oh no you can't use
that information it is opaque to hidden
it's behind the abstraction barrier
do not cross but that's just an
interpretation there's another way of
looking at the program that gives you
the opposite conclusion suppose the
sanitize function is not allowed to know
what the sanitize means I don't know
what it returns but you can't show with
sanitize function doesn't know what that
means but this other code doesn't know
what sanitize means then it works when
you do our backhands but not when you
call this foreign function who knows
what it does but of course eros there's
in the third option in which both never
accessible this is the hippie version
there is no abstraction boundary
everyone gets know about sanitization
those dirty hippies and in that case in
both modules you're allowed to think
about definite sanitize and see that
these line up and you either now when
you're actually programming you know
write down these formal logic things you
don't write preconditions and
postconditions in gratuitous detail and
everything no you have an idea in your
head about what you're supposed to do
but it's not given to the compiler and
so for all three of these
interpretations all three these worlds
whoever's allowed to know what sanitized
means these all result in the same code
the difference is only at level three in
the logic in the why not in level two
code but it's it's still which one of
these worlds you choose is your
interpretation determines which often is
correct and preferable so is it just a
matter of interpretation well there's
some pretty clear like everything's a
trade-off but there are some pretty
clear reasons to pick option one so an
option one I'm all sanitized and I need
a sanitized ring for save so I could
have sanitized X I need a show of
sanitizers acts in order to save it and
this proof is trivial not was it trivial
but trying program in Coke I can
actually type in the words a trivial
period and will say yep that's a proof
and more generally it can get more
complicated when you have aliasing and
conditionals but it's still going to
fall within a fragment of first-order
logic called effectively propositional
or EPR logic which is generally pretty
easy to reason about there are fast
algorithms in the other world I'm doing
this replace all thing my hands I need
show it satisfies some complicated
condition about what goes where and we
can do this but it's a little bit harder
it's so hard that was only discovered
this year so in the first case when I
first write sanitize I still need to
prove that's when I standardized a
string it satisfies the meaning of being
sanitized and so there aren't either
thing a little bit harder about the
sanitize function but when I actually
use it I can use the fast EPR logic
solver it's easy for me it's easier for
this program to think about whereas in
the other options I don't have to clean
module boundary and so when I call save
with this complicated do by hand replace
all in now I need to use the very fancy
turn algorithm and think about strings
and one it's also easier for the with
the synthesizer because if I say okay I
have a string now I need a stand-in tie
string and I need to satisfy this son
condition about what goes where
everythings escapes it's like okay look
how can I get a c-h-i string mmm mr. way
to use replace all's we can catenate
things or way to reverse things it has a
lot of options and choose from in trying
it search when you say it is sanitized
what does that mean you know that's on a
need-to-know basis then it is only one
option for how to get a cm tie string
which is to call the sanitize function
which exports an interface saying gives
you a sanitized string and so that's
it's a precise meaning of easy to think
about and easier to code synthesis style
so we've explored some and
correspondences between the detective
schools at synthesis and you and we've
seen the themes of abstraction in the
way that we hated it he'd sanitize
behind the abstraction barrier do not
cross how this put constraints on the
program and what is it possible to write
and of course all this only seen at the
level of logic let's look at another
example how is it possible to write a
straight line program nope no
indentation that contains a conditional
let's find out I have a program on the
server returns for nine six ever swear
it returns one A two four and my friend
Steven sees this code and he sees that
if statement and he gets mad because the
Internet's told him do not use if
statements death to the estate man join
the into F campaign if statements are
bad hmm
so it goes back his code he's an idea
this is in C that is on server variables
either zero or one we can replace this
if with
Iranian debts yes the Guru is not
pleased hmm
you have only moved the conditioner into
the RA what so this is the anti if
advice a little bit less straightforward
then it may have scenes let's see if
that means a quick change of notation
I'm going to denote the array 1 2 2 4
496 by saying start with the empty array
at 0 insert 1 or 2 for ads 1 insert 496
on top of this notation we have the
array axioms and then I'm not gonna go
with them in detail but they tell me
exactly what it means
for it they told me exactly what it
means for for 2 indexed array and it
gives me this says that's 1 the in the
index is 4 9 6 else let's go deep in the
array and 0 it's 1 or 2 for now let's go
deeper through a oh we're out of a rain
we're out of axioms and now it's so now
it's undefined but really the only thing
you care about is at the bottom right
this simplifies to the formula if x
equals 0 then the index is 1 and 2 4 and
if X is 1 then the index is 4 9 6 that
formula is conditional if X exists and
it's that if X is this then it's a matte
now using this we can go back to the
program and come a full arch or formulas
to describe what the program does and we
get a conditional if done server then
it's 496 else it's 1 or 2 4 and we can
use other axioms to do the exact same
for the original program and we get the
exact same formula and so there's a
sense that both these have an additional
the same conditional and so the
synthesizer is only looking at these
formulas and so from its perspective
these two pieces of code are not just
semantically equivalents you're actually
structurally identical we haven't
changed it at all and so conditionals
are a semantic notion not syntactic
notion just because you don't ride
through the words the letter is AI F
does not mean there's no if statement in
your code so the thing that happened
here was the array index was a
conditional in disguise does this mean
we should have an anti-air a campaign
and no array is deathly array no not
every array access is a conditional but
the difference is subtle and it cannot
be purely Terman from the code but is a
property of rather of the level three
how do you think about it let's inspect
here's another array it's a list of all
the president names I'm using now we can
define a president after function the
president after Washington was Adams the
president after Thomas Jefferson was
James Madison and so on here's a pretty
simple function that does that it
totally breaks on bad inputs negatives
negatives the last president don't tell
me about those it's simple I example and
let's talk about what it means index is
array and like before we get a giant
conditional at zero what's Washington
and it's one it's Adams and so on it's
does not look promising it's conditional
but if you already have a notion an
external notion of the iith president
then you can relate this formula to that
and you can get this simpler formula
it's the index of the eye it's a name
the Ides president which is not involve
any ranch knee at all and now we can use
this extracted formula to think of look
at this code and think about it in a
very straightforward manner did this
index I could name the next president
and I'm done that's how you would think
about it and that's also how a verify or
synthesizer would think about it just
like everything not here there's no case
working here there's no branching just
works and so that's a sense in which one
array index is
and the other is not so the difference
is that we were able to abstract one and
not the other maybe you could abstract
the size array find a better way of
thinking about it but I didn't and
because I didn't find a way that was
conditional and and this one is not so
we've again seen this insight from the
doctoral school synthesis the human and
when he's seen a Miss traction and how
we track in the array access this lets
us put extra constraints to program like
death via statement but this only is can
be understood at a level of logic let's
go to another school of synthesis the
constraint based and this section is
going to be a little bit different from
previous ones I said at the beginning
that a human and deductive synthesizer
were kind of somewhere and so deductive
synthesis can shed light on soft
engineering advice where the numerator
constraint based they're not like a
human synthesizer so they're just going
to eliminate the nature of the program's
themselves we're gonna be talking about
a tool called sketch built by my advisor
Armando slow azama and it sketched about
programming with holes like humans are
clever and insightful and slow
synthesizers are dumb Thor and fast
let's put them together you're gonna
write a high level with a program what
the permanent kind of looks like the
synthesizers are gonna fill the details
so here's the hello world example that
question marks is a hole and so this
thing is asking find me an integer
question mark such an x x question mark
is equivalent to x times X or all for
all inputs and you might figure out the
answer it's 2 and the synthesizer will
figure that out too after is 0.45 2
seconds you can do more crops via things
life sketch like if you have a really
inefficient linkless reversal you can
get the fast one you do need a bit more
of a complicated hole than the integer
it's say like some number of statements
where statement looks like this but it
can do it
so let me to give you with a two minute
and version of the synthesis of the
synthesis algorithm it's two parts
constraint solving and the see just loop
so it looks like this let's for
simplicity all integers are two bits
you'll think we had in a moment and we
can just say let's look at the bits of
the input and the whole and your it
expressions and all these give us
constraints that the bits of the digits
of the plus expression need to match the
corresponding ones then in the
multiplication expression so we get a
list of constraints on the bits and now
we can also write down bits level
formulas for every bit of the plus and
the times it looks like this something
boolean formulas thank goodness he's
only two bit number is and now we'll
just solve for what the bits of the
whole are and if you're taking it to
your computing course you might start
getting a little scared cousin if your
computing course you might have learned
that this is the boolean satisfiability
problem we need to find assigned to
these bits the thing works
that's the sap problem oh no that's
np-hard and that is a lie because it's
actually empty easy and by that I mean
that modern Sat solvers can take in
millions of variables and solve them
very fast most of the time in this case
we're luckily enough to be in the most
of the time and so we figure out the
bits of the whole and we gave the final
answer of two what is this but but
really it's it makes it easy to think
about if we just pick a few inputs at
one time instead of all inputs so on top
of this we build something called the
counter example guided inductive
synthesis loop sieges and it's basically
conversation between two parts the
inductive synthesizer and the verifier
the inductive synthesizer takes some
input take some test gives you a program
the verifier takes in a program and says
if it always works if not a feeling
inputs so does this work no it fails it
but does this work no is a
Tass does this work yes in other words
CJIs is test-driven development and from
this I get the idea
maybe you can somehow you sketch and
CJIs to tell us something about testing
let's do it what we're going to do is I
want to see if my test case is good
enough if it's good enough in the test
pass my program works so is there a way
to write write a program that passes all
my tests but is the wrong program let
you use synthesis to find out so a view
of testing is that you have some space
of correct programs that you want to
find and every test is going to narrow
down the passing programs more and more
hopefully to just the correct ones well
there's something missing from this
story here's a very simple kind of
program curves on an XY plane if your my
test points and I want a curve that goes
through all three points
can you guess what curve I have in mind
that's right it's this guy no no no
here's another test oh you mean this one
but if we add a structural constraints
that the curve must be aligned then
those two options go away the only
option is this line and not only that
but I need fewer points to your test
cases and programs are just generalized
polynomials and parking fits this is
just generalized curve fitting so what
does this look like for testing programs
well if you have some kind of strong
from whence train the programs you can
write then maybe you don't need this
third test so let's put that in action
so I want to synthesize a function to do
something very complicated get the
length of a linked list here are my
three test cases on the left and for
this I do but for this I do need to have
some kind of Oracle that tells me what
the correct answer is using this I'm
gonna synthesize a length function which
passes all the three tests they gave its
whether it is some inputs list question
mark which differs from the correct
answer so castle the test cases but it's
wrong on somewhere
let's synthesize so first I say it'll
have at most three branches each
conditional looks something like this
some reasonable list operations now
here's what's gonna happen within each
branch and let's see you can come up
with something and it does sketch
produces correct output not readable
output and so in order to make sure I
have the right program I need to add
another test like list of length three
and now it says you if it pass all the
tests there's no way to make it the
wrong program but if I restrict my
program a little bit then I don't need
that test anymore and just the only
three tests I must have the correct
program so there's all this talk about
more coverage more tests more precise
but we don't as here often hear about
writing the simpler code in that the
more of one we have the less the other
we need write some bar code then you
don't need as many tests as a try and
it's it's a choice but I know which end
I prefer because there's a saying that
quality cannot be tested in quality must
be built in and this is what it means so
we've gotten some insights into writing
programs writing tests from the school
of constraint based synthesis and again
we've seen abstraction in our use of
this test Oracle constraints and how
we've checked the program space to make
it work and we used and this is this
album itself is based on logic so we've
seen a lot of stuff today gone you
you've learned the high level two
different synthesis algorithms yeah see
seen a lot of stuff you probably haven't
seen before but really what we're doing
he's reaching that black box in your
head of how we write programs
and kind of opening up a bit and seeing
how it works and and in doing so we can
start to stop accepting a vague answers
for what we should be doing know start
to accept maybe you can think a little
bit deeper about what's going on
what is it possible for me to write
right now programs aren't a wild-west
not anything goes there's a structure to
what it's possible to write and work
something that we can find it so so my
hope is that we come here today you're
joining me all you're all joining me on
a journey to get away from the citrus
advice become used to start to learn how
to see the vitamins in our code because
the first step
you've our most important step you've
already done to get to more precise
cautionary advice the big step is simply
to believe that it's possible because
you are a program synthesizer so it's in
quick so if you want to see more about
this check out my blog I love this stuff
I also teach it I have a web core
starting in two weeks we have one our
former students sitting right there I'd
like to thank all the people who made
this possible people invented what I
talked about Wells organizers but most
importantly st. Louis is my hometown and
so we have a very special guest be
honest today I'd like to thank my father
for never telling me that I'm crazy even
when he thought it
remember you are you are a program
synthesizer and do not cross the streams
and do not cross the abstraction
boundary okay so one minute for
questions ball stay as long as I have
askers so it's late for this to load
while it's loading I'll take your hands
yep it loaded no let's see do not see
any questions okay Oh if there are no
questions it is great to see you all
today and I hope you had a great Strange
Loop
[Applause]